okay we have a stunning new poll I
mentioned this at the top of the show
there is a new poll from Quinnipiac
University which reveals that most
Americans by a significant margin
believe that Donald Trump is a criminal
there's no other way to say it okay
there are news outlets who are trying to
report on this poll without actually
just saying the thing that the poll says
which is most Americans 64% believe that
Trump is a criminal that the president
is a criminal let's look at some of the
poll results question one do you think
that President Trump committed any
crimes before he was president 64% of
Americans believed that the president
committed crimes before he was president
of the United States but that's not the
only time that we have reason to believe
the president has committed crimes what
about what has taken place while he has
been president of the United States on
the question do you think that President
Trump has committed any crimes while he
has been president forty five percent of
Americans believe that he has and 43
percent of Americans believe that he is
not it's important to understand that
many of the people who believe the
president has not committed crimes since
he has been president believe that
because they don't think when the
president does it it's a crime in other
words some of that 43 percent does
believe that the actions that Trump has
taken since becoming president would be
crimes for anyone but the President of
the United States very important sort of
footnote to those numbers another really
interesting data point from this new
Quinnipiac poll do people find President
Trump or Michael Cohen more trustworthy
asking in general who do you believe
more Trump or Cohen only thirty five
percent of Americans believe Donald
Trump's version of events over Michael
Cohen's 50% of Americans trust Michael
Cohen over Donald Trump more people
believe that the convicted felon who is
about to go to prison is more credible
than the President of the United States
and then lastly people
he'll really want to see Donald Trump's
tax returns on the question do you think
Donald Trump should publicly release his
tax returns or not 64% of Americans
believe that he should 29% believed that
he shouldn't and 7% don't know or not
applicable so the important thing to
take away from this pad is that this is
the 2020 election what I mean by that is
the cloud of criminality the endless
investigations this is going to be the
context of Donald Trump's 2020
re-election campaign and the most
disturbing thing about these numbers is
that there is overlap mathematically
there has to be overlap between people
who believe that Donald Trump is a
criminal and people who approve of the
job that Donald Trump is doing as
president and that Pat is why we have to
just get out the vote if someone
believes Trump's a criminal and is still
going to vote for him that's not someone
I want to waste my time trying to
convince to vote for somebody else
yeah it's tribalism at its worst it's
like they admit that he's a criminal but
he's their criminal he's doing
criminality on their behalf so they're
going to support him on the Kohen point
I think that's interesting that more
people believe Cohen a convicted liar
than Trump but it makes perfect sense
because Cohen was convicted of lies that
he told at the behest of Trump while
working for Trump under Trump's
discretion and now he's come clean and I
think that's why people see him as more
credible now so I think those numbers do
add up even though initially it kind of
raises some questions this is why we
need get out the vote do not worry about
convincing trumpets what could you
possibly say to talk sense into someone
who believes Trump's a criminal but
believes that he should be elected
whatever you can say will be more work
than just convincing a few left wingers
who don't usually vote to get out there
and vote for somebody other than Donald
Trump I want to hear from you what do
you take away from these poll numbers
what do you think this means about the
upcoming sort of atmosphere around the
2020 reelection campaign of Donald Trump
I want to hear from you on Twitter at
the Pakman you can also follow the show
on Twitter
at david pakman show one of today's
sponsors is privacy calm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below